I appreciate that that this is knives
out and then you said sharp it's just
nice buns
I know knife puns believe me yeah hello
who are you talking to the girl where
knives have like played a very big part
in my life yeah you seem to not be able
to get away from no you would think I
would have been sorry and come out with
a knife set like the jlc knife set would
have been a good like cross branding or
whatever they say the best time to do
something was 10 years ago and the
second best time is today so you can
already start you can always done knife
set stay tuned QVC you guys look like
you're having the time your last so
doing that with you and sell my knife
sets with me only it's like whenever she
gets on a guess on a roll you just hit a
piano key to her soul you sit back love
it people are gonna be watching this
going like he sits back and goes do what
move y'all no let me see the movie um
ryan johnson brain must be just amazing
what were you guys trying to poke holes
in in his plot in the story and in plain
sight because it's so airtight it has to
be you know it's one of those things
were i with ryan he would there was I
think he just did a couple of things we
kind of like but it literally was like
tiny tunings nothing there was no it was
like the plot was there everything was
it and and also you kind of just have to
sort of trust it to sort of be there you
know it's complicated it's complicated a
lot happened but what runs through this
story which is sort of more important
than any of it really the whodunit
overall and everything is sort of the
heart of the movie which is Anna's story
and it's sort of with and the reality of
what's going on the emotion of it and
that's what pulls the movie along
so the whodunit and the kind of mystery
of it is just the crazy people is just
lovely is it's just kind of the sort of
delicious delightful stuff that you kind
of get to go with it I mean
how good a movie I think it is I think I
mean and that's Ryan's brain as a movie
maker understanding what was needed for
this genre but also what is needed for
yeah but no I was good no no because I'm
agreeing with you
ultimately there I don't want to name
them but there are a couple of
filmmakers who are also deep dive
historians who know every second of
cinema history but they also let you
know they know every second of cinema
history in their persona and in the way
they speak and in the way they talk
about it and Brian is not that God is
not elitist he's not elitist he seems
incredibly quiet yes and sort of
down-to-earth there he does not take up
any space in the room with his
intelligence but his giggle when you're
funny
uh-huh is all you need not it's like you
can do this big scene and then from just
off by the monitors you hear this little
cackle II laughs and then you know oh we
hit it we actually played the note
speaking of cinema history do you have a
favorite murder mystery movie of all
time
III I mean it's it's I I really like
murder on the order to express with
Albert Finney honey because I'm so like
Albert from because Albert Finney I
could just watch do anything sir but I'm
gonna say you know I weirdly enough
although I haven't seen it in probably
20 years the last of Sheila which is
this weird movie that Ryan also loves
right I think it was the first murder
mystery I ever saw I think I was a
teenager it was a screening at a
friend's house to put that on my list
another the last Sheila Austin one
that'll go right after this one okay I
had so much fun as me because yes sir
yes thank you so much